hello readers today I'll make a video
about summaries a summary retells the
main ideas of a passage but in a much
shorter version cool great done you can
learn anything Dave it out sorry I made
a goof see I summarized what was gonna
happen in this video right I took the
information I was going to tell you and
I shortened it this is what the skill of
summarizing is I just applied it to this
video instead of to a story when you
summarize you have to ask yourself what
are the most important facts what are
the most important details you're a
reporter a stringer a journal your job
is to get in get the facts and get out
it's the news in brief just the facts
ma'am take the three little pigs for
instance I'll summarize it now him three
little pigs live in houses that they
built one used straw one used wood and
the third Pig who worked hardest of all
built a brick house along comes a big
bad wolf pictured here with a big bad
top hat and a big bad house wrecking
hammer I don't know and he successfully
knocks down the first two houses in
order to eat the pigs inside but they
escaped to the brick house which the
wolf is unable to knock down that's the
important parts of the story and I bet I
could even cut that down a little bit
but here's what's there all the
important characters all their major
decisions and the outcome of the story
we have the beginning the middle and the
end now let me show you what too little
information looks like there were three
pigs they built houses a big bad wolf
tried to get them not enough that's not
enough information it doesn't tell us
whether or not the wolf succeeded or the
important differences between the three
pig houses not enough as far as facts go
you know it's got it's got to be
specific and look it's possible to go in
the opposite direction too too many
irrelevant facts so there were three
pigs one's name was Horace another's
name was pansy and the thirds name was
fluster fur they had all been friends
since middle school and when the market
was in a good place all three of them
decided to go in for plots of land right
next to each other
that right but that's that's too much in
a summary I don't need the whole story
if it were the whole story it wouldn't
be a summary it would just be the whole
story all over again
keep it simple we need the events of the
story in the order they happened in we
need the characters and we need the
problems they face and for a summary
that's kind of it you can learn anything
Dave it out for real this time bye